el primer día del nuevo confinamiento en
alemania llegó con un récord negativo
novecientos cincuenta y dos muertes por
coronavirus en las últimas 24 horas es
el undécimo día laboral consecutivo con
más de 400 muertes diarias y esto ayuda
a explicar no solamente lo dramática que
es la situación actualmente en alemania
sino también las razones detrás de estas
nuevas restricciones el confinamiento
irá a partir de este miércoles hasta el
próximo 10 de enero inicialmente
dependiendo de cómo evolucionen los
números todos los establecimientos
considerados no esenciales deberán
cerrar y se les ha pedido a los alemanes
que reduzcan sus contactos al mínimo con
una muy pequeña excepción durante los
días más importantes de la navidad de
tal manera que los alemanes puedan
reunirse con sus familiares más cercanos
la esperanza está puesta en que estas
nuevas restricciones ayuden a reducir
los muy altos números de contagiados y
la esperanza también está puesta en que
antes de navidad' pueda llegar la
aprobación europea para qué
a entregarse la vacuna contra el
coronavirus alemán ya se ha estado
preparando ya durante varias semanas
para poder distribuir la vacuna tan
pronto llegue la autorización europea